all right we're on we're all let's do
this hey hey rowdy
hey what's how's it going Rodney oh good
what's the question for you are you for
you being a video right now yeah like
what do you got first question how well
do you know your wife I know pretty well
you know I mean it's like three years so
pretty good pretty gratulations yeah do
you know your wife's bra size why why do
you want to know her bra size oh I don't
want to know her bra size I want to know
if you do because I want to see if you
can go shopping right now for a bra for
your wife and then she'll try it on
we'll see you later how why you did that
mean it'll be kind of hard she's
pregnant she's got bigger boobs now is
great so you're completely clueless oh
yeah precisely I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen fantastic well I
want you to go right now this camera's
gonna follow you so this is free Rodney
oh go go for it let's go for it
let's go bye hope this works out
it's gonna be a little tricky my wife's
pregnant her boobs are fluctuating a
little bit and there's actually like
this is kind of gross but milk is
starting to come out of my where do I
start
we got the bras here we found them this
is like a bathing suit I don't know if I
can rock this for my wife you're some
bigger ones I'm not saying my wife is a
big lady but her boobs are pretty big
right now okay this is a seed and this
already looks like giant normal I could
do like a kind of visual like a
flashback of my wife this like flesh
colored one would be cool because she's
just gonna rock it around the house I
don't know is that what girls do when
they buy bras this color my wife's
breasts or more like full and I guess
more has more volume I guess is a good
word
hey this kind of looks good a little
little too big but I feel like this can
be like the guide all right let's go
lift natural natural I'm guessing real
boobs
because if you have big boobs you
probably would need a lift light natural
okay invisible just the terminology that
there's so much why these are like wings
now I think this might be the one though
I think this right here a 40 D I mean
this has to be the one gonna be so good
so comfortable for her big old milk jugs
where's a mirror oh there's a mirror in
here oh yeah no one knows my wife better
than me so we're gonna go with the 40 D
and we're bringing it home all right
love you babe I'm gonna yeah you got
this this is all you
so first reactions how do you feel about
that off oh yeah he zip it off we're
gonna actually bring out the bra that he
picked for you to try right now can we
actually bring out our entire rack of
bras please excuse the pun of a rack of
bras right this way set it right over
here I believe can we just have you try
that on right now over your clothes
we'll see how well he did this four
clasps on this maximum security we can
maybe put the baby in here you are the
ultimate judge in this situation how do
you think Ronnie did and picking out a
bra for you I'm happy it's too big and
not too small he won he won yeah take
care of say goodbye everybody wave
goodbye